foreign
[Music]
here I thought we were special fellas
this here's Bag Man hang man whatever
what the hell kind of mission is this
[Music]
the best there is who the hell are they
gonna get to teach us
Captain p Eep Maverick Mitchell
let me be perfectly blocked you are not
my first choice you were here at the
request of Admiral kazanski AKA Iceman
he seems to think that you have
something left to offer the Navy
what that is I can't imagine
it's all due respect sir I'm not a
teacher just want to manage expectations
this is your captain speaking
and we're off
here we are intrigued
we're going into combat on a level no
living Pilots ever seen not even him
you think up there you're dead
my dad believed in you
I'm not gonna make the same mistake
[Music]
as soon as I come back from this
those are your Pilots anything happens
to them
you'll never forgive yourself
no turning back now come on
[Music]
come on having any fun yet
our lives
are the sum of our choices
foreign
this mission of yours
is gonna cost you dearly
the world is changing
truth is Vanishing war is coming
it's been a long time
you've no idea the power I represents
it knows your story and How It Ends
listen to me the world's coming after
you
his fate is written
shall we write yours too if anything
happens to them there's no place that I
won't go to kill you that
foreign
what's your objective
what's your ultimate objective
your life will always matter more to me
than my own
none of our Lives can matter More Than
This Mission I don't accept that
[Music]
thank you
look at me positive for Howard marks I'm
placing you under arrest for the future
murder of Sarah marks and Donald Duman
that was take place today April 22nd
it's zero eight hundred hours four
minutes
foreign
don't run
everybody runs French
[Music]
foreign
take care of our kids you got nothing to
worry about
that is so weird the wind is blowing
toward the storm
lightning doesn't strike twice
Robbie you saw the lightning yeah 26
times Lincoln Avenue
[Music]
you see that
thank you
I'm taking you to the car You're Gonna
Wanna look around
but you're not going to are you
[Music]
listen to me there's three of us
foreign
[Music]
I'm gonna tell you a story
at first it's gonna sound ridiculous but
the longer I talk we have to find the
keys the more rational it's going to
appear I can't believe you found coffee
sugar right yeah hold on three
how many times have we been here
how many times for me it's been an
eternity
[Music]
The Invasion will fail
we lose everything
I die within five minutes of landing on
that beach along with every other
Soldier
please
how did you do that come on come find me
when you wake up
you do know what's happening to me
what happened to you happened to me you
high power how do I control it you have
to die every day keep coming here and
I'll train you
again again your legs broken no I'm good
I think we better start over oh come on
you're a weapon
they want to conquer the rest of the
world
unless you change the outcome we are not
equipped
how many times have we been here
what are you not telling me
it's gonna be dark in a few hours one
curl up by the fire and open a bottle of
wine
just reset whoa
that's at the United States drug
enforcement agency we are ordering you
to land I voices
my name is Barry seal
that's for the damage for your sister
hey little darling and you're back
some of this really happened if you
never saw me
top of your class in the Civil Air
Patrol pilot like you shouldn't be
flying buses welcome to Miami welcome to
Bakersfield haven't you ever wanted
something more Barry you should be
serving your country
we need you to deliver stuff for us
oh this is legal if you're doing it for
the good guys
very sealed it's a goddamn genius
you are airline pilot Barry that's how
you support this family this is gonna be
good for us
you trust me no
we're expanding operations Barry
[Music]
Roscoe dug this up in the backyard there
are bills blowing around everywhere I'll
rake it up in the morning
guns drugs money laundering
did you all know that caddies have more
trunk space than any other car I'll get
each and every one of you a cat to hear
troubles say I'm gonna walk out of here
I don't read a damn thing any one of you
can do about it
well wait a minute boys should have
taken a case
I was working for the CIA the DEA and
Pablo
escobarentos that's 1500 kilos in one go
get it done
[Music]
there cannot be peace without first a
great suffering
the greater the suffering the greater
the peace
the in you always fear is
[Music]
coming
and the blood will be on your hands
I pray to God that it wasn't true
Solomon Lane escaped in Paris
now the world is at risk
cia's Mission you you use a scabble
I prefer a hammer
this is a bad idea is it ever a good one
honestly
he's not just some Observer he's an
assassin I don't trust anybody outside
of this room
you go Roe he's been authorized to hunt
you down and kill you
it's the job
no hard feelings
Which Way veggie turn left
what are you waiting for I'm jumping out
a window
oh sorry good luck
who's everyone he ever cared about
you don't understand what you're
involved in you need to walk away
please don't make me go through you
think that's not who we are
maybe we need to reconsider that
[Music]
accepted either you've lost this one
once done is done
what stone is done when we say it's done
Showtime oh my God
foreign
[Music]
whoever served in an infantry unit son
no sir ever served in a forward area
ever put your life in another man's
hands asked him to put his life and
yours no sir we follow orders son we
follow orders or people die it's that
simple are we clear
yes are we clear crystal
all those having business with this
general court marshall stand forward and
you shall be heard if that's the case
are these on midnight of September 6 he
accused entered the barracks room with
their platoon mate they woke him up tied
his arms and legs with tape forced to
rag into his throat a few minutes later
a chemical reaction caused his lungs to
begin bleeding he drowned in his own
blood and was pronounced dead at 37
minutes past midnight you think Santiago
was murdered private Santiago is dead
and that is a tragedy
but he is dead because he had no code he
is dead because he had no honor
and God was watching how do you feel
about that theory sounds good to me I'll
knock it all down to involuntary
manslaughter No Deal we're going to
court no you're not why not because
you'll lose you want to investigate me
roll the dice and take your chances I
eat breakfast 300 yards from 4 000
Cubans who were trained to kill me so
don't think for one second you can come
down here flash a badge and make me
nervous
you meant following orders of people die
you want answers I think I'm entitled
you want answers the truth you can't
handle the truth son we live in a world
that has walls and those walls have to
be guarded by men with guns who's gonna
do it you if this case is handling the
same fast food slick ass Persian bizarre
manners which you seem to handle
everything else and something's going to
get missed in the heart of the nation's
capital
the courthouse of the United States
government one man will stop at nothing
to keep his honor and one will stop at
nothing to find the truth
[Music]
thank you
you know if you just listen to me we'd
be all bogged down in traffic right now
and you would have made yourself an
extra five bucks yeah when you keep that
five bucks buy something special
[Music]
Thanks Max
hey come on I'll take it
I got five stops to make what's your
name Max Max I'm Vincent all right
I'm using the alley behind the building
red light Max hold on hold on man you
were gonna drive me around tonight never
be the wiser but we're in the plan b
you got to make the best of it improvise
adapt to the environment whatever man we
gotta roll with it
just met him once again like that but I
should only kill people after I get to
know them
I'm not up for this
[Laughter]
what are you gonna do about it
there's a man named Vincent I got
another deal Wade
he's already killed Witnesses he's
coming to kill you
[Music]
what's going what's my work
gotta roll with it
with that get your hand in the air
that's fun coming from you
slow down
[Laughter]
foreign
we can save you from total Destruction
[Music]
we have to show the world that not all
of us will like him
a greater risk
it doesn't change what we must do
what did you have in mind
you could serve Germany for the fury not
both it's just that talk that had you
sent here Colonel what I said was much
worse
Soldier
but in serving my country I have
betrayed my conscience we need to
reorganize there has to be a chance of
success
that's why you're here
Hitler's Germany has seen its last
sunrise can I count you in
any problem on Earth can be solved with
a careful application of high explosives
trick is not to be around when they go
off 10 minutes what
two for them one to the bumper six to
get up
plenty of time but remember nothing ever
goes according to plan
operation Valkyries in effect
if their catch you they will pull you
apart
if I fail they'll come to you
all of you I know do you realize what
you've done
[Music]
I've been discovered every second we
stand here there's a second last
if you want to lifted tonight you'll do
exactly as I say what makes you think
you're stronger than the very momentum
of History
my fear of May I present colonel
stavenberg
thank you
I want everybody to see you for what you
are the best kept secret in the NFL you
are the man you ready yup let's go my
name is Jerry Maguire I'm a sports agent
you could say I'm at the top of my game
something just isn't right
what can I do for you show me the money
can you sign my card sorry little fella
I can't sign this brand of card only pro
jam blue dye cards and lately it's
getting worse came here to let you go
pardon me I came here to fire you Jerry
don't worry I'm not gonna do what you
all think I'm gonna do which is just
flip out who's coming with me who is
coming
with me
I will go with you Dorothy Boyd thank
you
we're gonna be okay because I am going
to take my one client and we're gonna go
all the way help me Rod help me help you
help me help you you are hanging on by a
very thin thread and I dig that about
you you want to go out to dinner
some dudes might have the coin but
they'll never have the Quan Quan it
means love wish me luck
hey that is the first time I have ever
seen him kiss a man just like a dad who
would cry at the beginning of a date
yeah just cry at the end like I do
[Music]
if the words you say are right
she'll let you deep inside
there's a scene
God and she had
my whole life I've been trying to talk I
mean
really talk
but
no one wants to listen to me you know
that feeling you know that feeling
is it possible to miss a place you've
never been
to mourn a time you've never lived
do you have any memories
for the security one our job is not to
remember
okay one six four four Tower four nine
this is Mission Control how y'all doing
this lovely morning
it's Jack Harper I'm good to go are you
you an effective team we are an
effective team
won the war
on the planet
Humanity had to leave the Earth and to
unlearn what it meant to call something
our home
remnants of the scavenger Army still
remain on the surface my job is security
and drone maintenance or the mop-up crew
166 is back online
oh my God we have an unidentified impact
drones are mobile keep your attack out
of vehicles they are human I'm ordering
you to return to Tower immediately
firing on survivors
does he bring back old memories where is
she I've been watching you Jack
they lied to you it's time to learn the
truth
Becca we need to leave now come
on
[Music]
who are you
swore
mankind to survive this is the only way
[Music]
I feel the need
the Need for Speed this February talk to
me Goose Top Gun is an IMAX
and for the first time ever experience
the movie that defined your generation
in 3D
what man
watch the birdie
firing
Top Gun in IMAX 3D for six days only
February 8th through the 13th for more
information go to facebook.com
topgunmovie
[Music]
Jack Reacher is a ghost served in the
military police
a brilliant investigator
Troublemaker too then two years ago he
disappears you don't find this guy
unless he wants to be found
excuse me sir there's a Jack Reacher
here to see you
can I help you James Barr
I say shot five people
I don't believe he did what exactly are
you saying he was framed
what does an army cop do mostly but you
choose one minor difference every
suspect was a train killer
what do we hope to find the truth
the soldier is asking questions no one
else would ask get the lawyer
Ellen no Helen are you hurt not to tell
you how this works do you think I'm a
hero I am not a hero
lawyer's all yours
on second thought I'd like to kill you
they want me to run
but I'm gonna finish this
you're a little rusty Mr Rachel
I have nothing to lose if you're smart
that scares you
oh
he doesn't care about the law
he doesn't care about proof
he only cares about what's right
[Music]
[Applause]
something happened in here
don't you die on me Foley
I'm sorry can we cut
what is going on here I'm about to jump
off this the Celica like Wesley I'm
doing the scene right now I mean the
scene is about emotionality where is it
oh God I am dealing with a bunch of
primadonna
fridge open
ER critically acclaimed Australian actor
Kirk Lazarus underwent a controversial
procedure in order to play the platoon's
African-American Sergeant I know who I
am I'm a dude playing the dude disguises
another dude
take a picture of this
summer I want to make this movie right
you take those boys up there put them in
the trees ship the whole thing gorilla
Style real fear in the Ride
the movie they think they're making
exterior rainforest dust cut to a
frightening jungle he's in the movie
anymore
[Music]
exactly let's use it
I got speed man
some of us might not make it back what
do you mean like not on the same flight
hey dude you all right totally lean into
that bro you wanna do one more
what do you mean you people
[Music]
Tropic Thunder Dakota trying just to get
a bed here no way up in a big league
that's the theme song for The Jeffersons
ain't nothing wrong there you out of
your mind you really need help yeah just
because theme song don't make it not
true
foreign
[Music]